wow
what an amazing couple of days um
we've i've learned a whole ton of stuff
and
what an amazing time to live working on
the internet
there's uh so much cool technology we've
got progressive web apps and
and wasms and machine learnings and
there's so much information on how to
make our website so fast
um and there's great content about
accessibility and usability and user
experience
oh we have service workers or sorry
service workers
the official logo um google i o last
month said that
uh service workers is like the biggest
step forward in a decade
and it's given us offline and push
notifications and
uh you know our website's gonna be even
more performant
and there are articles and and twitter
and
and social media is kind of going on
about how fast our websites have to be
and i feel really tired and i
and and it's draining and i want to go
back to a better time where things were
a little more old school a bit more
slower
and and louder and uglier
so i'm going to throw all of the cool
stuff that you've learned
over the last year and try and try and
go back to that
that awful experience so before i
proceed i do have a couple of content
warnings
the first one is i do have some flashing
imagery in my
um my talk it's not a huge amount of
screen but you'll see the
the icon up in the corner um
there is some disorientating sounds um
again you'll see the icon up in the
corner before it starts playing
and there is some questionable
javascript so um
judge me all you want but it won't make
it any better
so hello my name is remy sharp um maybe
you've
seen my work js bin i
i run a conference ff conf in the uk
i've got a couple of little projects no
mon or no demon
or no demon depending on how you want to
pronounce it and i was a child of the
80s obviously as i am clearly dressed as
mr t
here with uh with the beard and the
earrings um
and i grew up in the uk during the 80s
and there was an explosion of technology
happening at that time i was privileged
enough to kind of be in a household
where my father
um was into computers as well and uh as
well
like it was a thing that was happening
and
um we had this machine this was the the
my childhood machine that i remember
using so this is a
zx spectrum 48k um from
sinclair sinclair is kind of like the
apple
or microsoft at the time um and you're
in europe i think it's called timex some
maybe you've heard of it i'm not sure
and this came out in 1982 now
there's a couple of machines prior to
that in 1980 the
uh the sinclair released the zx80 for 50
pounds
50 pounds for a home computer in 1980
was staringly cheap compared to the fact
that
in the 70s there were machines the size
of rooms
for thousands of pounds so all of a
sudden
for 50 pounds which is about 200 euros
today
you could own a computer in your
household and all of a sudden you were
high-tech this is what i had as a kid
and instead of being uh parented i
played games on this
um mom and dad don't watch um
i love that one of the features here is
um the key is auto repeat
the key feature is like the the keys all
to
and to load the software onto these
machines you would have
a thing called a tape cassette tape for
those of you who are younger this is
like a really old [ __ ] usb stick
not anywhere near as robust and all
kinds of things will go wrong with these
tapes and you
you take your tape you load it into
cassette player um
and you would press play that would wire
into your spectrum
and um uh you
wire the spectrum into your television
um and you would you'd wait
um and you'd wait and um
sometimes the games wouldn't load and
sometimes the tape would unscrew so all
the tape will come out
sometimes it looks like jimi hendrix
here um
more often you wouldn't be as lucky
you'd end up having to kind of wind it
all back again
um and i canvassed twitter to ask people
you know for those of you
who actually had these things what would
you do to try and encourage the thing to
load
some people would uh leave the room so
the computer you know this this god-like
thing had to be alone
uh some people turn the machines upside
down i um i would just pray to the thing
please load please low please load um
and to be fair i still use this
technique on my
uh my phone so in truth
most of my childhood was spent listening
to these games loading so that's what
i want to recreate for you and bring
back the old school
using the only technology i know which
is a browser
obviously now just to give you full
context
um this is what it sounded like and look
like if i've forgotten
the uh the content warning there's gonna
be some loud noises here
and i will turn it down as we're going
um and it's a bit flashy too
so you want it from the beginning there
we go
[Music]
this is what you have to listen to every
time
i'll turn it down
so you're a kid of like six or seven and
you're waiting for this game
this is what you have to listen to okay
and this is just the loading screen
this is just the thing to tell you this
is what it might look like
assuming the tape doesn't go bad and the
spectrums themselves they were buggy
and they would fail so i'm going to
remake that
okay so the spectrum that loading
experience
one of the key parts is the sound um so
the sound is broken up into three parts
you've got the the pilot signal which is
like the steady tone that happened at
the beginning
and then there's a sync signal which is
like a burst of sound and then
i've got data and what we were listening
to just then was data
so i'm like all right i can do this i
know there's a web api for um
for sound so i'm going to just get a new
audio context and create an oscillator
and i'm going to set the the frequency
of the oscillators at 830 which is about
the right frequency
um i had a friend basically just open
this up in
audacity and tell me what the frequency
was and i connected to my destination
and i start
okay so that solid frequency is
um the pilot signal cool next bit
okay next bit is making a very distinct
sound
and i know how to make white noise i
know i can just chuck random data into
audio but this is distinct and it needs
to sound right otherwise it's just
it's all wrong so i've been working on
this for 12 months
uh on and off like not solidly full-time
or paid or anything like that but 12
months
learning about sound learning about
tones and
frequencies and um
processors and promptly forgot all that
stuff and you can basically just
fill buffers with samples um
so i didn't need to know anything about
how sound worked to be able to create
this
one amazing part of the web that i
absolutely love i
was able to go to a website called
worldofspectrum.org
and it was filled with um
like game content old files uh
documentation specifications people
there are people who have actually
reverse engineered the entire hardware
and made it work and documented all that
and shared on the web so
i know that the amplitude of the the
waveform is completely irrelevant
and the way the sound works is that um
it measures this
this kind of line as a pulse so the
point where it crosses the zero mark
and goes down below that is one pulse
and this has a length of 855 t states
a t state is one operation that the
zx spectrum can perform zx spectrum runs
at 3.5 megahertz so it can do
three and a half million operations per
second this is
uh 805 855 t states
uh which is a quarter of a millisecond
so to get this right i have to make a
quarter million
millisecond sound a pair of these pulses
is a binary zero
and twice the length is a binary one
okay
so i have a bunch of numbers now um and
i can use a bit of maths
i take my sample rate of uh 44 megahertz
which is like the default
audio context
sample rate i take my uh 3.5 megahertz
that's my t-state length
my i want to get the number of samples
required
to to to match the t state the t length
and that's basically the length at 855
multiplied by t
multiply by sample rate plus a little
bit more so they get a whole number
i can't have a half sample um and for
binary zero i can lend samples binary
one i get 22 samples i'm perfectly sure
no one is going to learn anything from
this bit of code so don't worry if
you're not following the code at this
point
but what i'm going to create is a buffer
that gives me a binary one and a binary
zero
and here i basically just have uh the
number of samples which is 11 for zero
i create a float array that has twice
the length
and i populate that with a plus one and
a negative one
and that gives me a binary zero
okay so now because like i've got binary
zero and binary one
i can go ahead and get the jsconf
homepage
i've got the the length of bytes that js
comp home pages by putting it putting
the array buffer into a unu
in eight array i multiply the bytes by
eight bits because there's eight bits in
a byte multiply by two because there's
two pulses per bit multiplied by the
what length of one and i get the number
of samples required
so to create the uh the buffer to be the
right size to be able to play
jsconf dot uh uh jsconf eu.html
i create an audio context set that
buffer populate it with
like this line here is just magic okay
and then i'm going to connect that to my
destination so yeah
so this is jsconf as audio
i'll put my volume back up so that you
can hear it clearly
i did warn them about not doing too
loudly
yeah this is uh the js music for next
year i'm telling you
[Applause]
yeah basically just hurt a lot of
people's ears and you're clapping me
um okay sound done next up is the bars
the loading bar is the other
super important part of making uh awful
loud ugly uh
images so there's a i think a really
cool backstory to the loading bars of a
spectrum
the original zx 80 had a chip called the
ula which is like the main brain of the
computer
and they had a restricted number of
chips so they they had
sorry restricted number of pins on the
chip and they had one
one pin managed all the display that
same pin
dealt with reading all of the audio
coming in so when audio came in
it would disrupt the display ever the
engineers this is not a bug this is a
feature
because you can see approximately what
the baud rate is
the data is going over the uh over the
audio um
and the engineers were kind of like well
we can see it's loading so
you know this is basically like a
loading bar from the 1980s and in fact
they code into the hardware and the
other
computer systems they went and coded
into their software like the commodore
for instance
um added this as a feature in their
their software when you loaded games
so i can't just take the bytes from js
conferences and dump it into a canvas
and kind of say
all the zeros are yellow and all the
ones are blue because it will just
do it too quickly and it'll be
completely out of sync so what i need to
do is take the audio i just generated
run it through a processor and then emit
bits that i'll then render on a canvas
so i have three choices for this um i
can use a
an analyzer node but that didn't really
work for me um it was it wouldn't give
me enough of the samples that comes off
the audio
and then i've got a script processor
node and the audio worklet
and um actually the script script
processor node has been deprecated
uh as of uh august 2014
in favor of the audio worklet and the
audio workload doesn't really have much
support in
many of the browsers today so i chose
the scriptpress
node um but it's pretty much the same
they
they're they're cool but basically
script processor will block the main
thread
which is what i want i want it to be a
little bit slower
okay so i've got my loud nasty noise
i connect up a script processor and um
the audio event fires and i get all the
samples
for that audio event i'm going to run
through all those samples i'm going to
do the opposite of what i was doing
before i'm going to look for the edges
of the sound
and the point where the the sample rate
goes from 0 to 1 and comes back down
again that's the width of my my pulse so
i'm going to build up pairs of pulses
find the bits and find the pairs of
pulses which make a bit
then build up a bit into a byte emit my
byte and
render it as a bar on the screen
first time i ran this i i was doing lots
of work with arrays and just kind of
moving data around an array
and um i ran a little uh performance
test
where i put all the audio through my
code and i was like well it's processing
like
i don't know two or three hundred
thousand samples from this this
three or four minutes of noise um it's
kind of slow
but when i looked at the profile i could
see this buffer.shift is taking up like
three seconds
i thought it's not mutation going on but
when i refactored it a little bit
and got rid of the shift and changed it
for a splice it completely changed the
uh the the performance profile
because of the way i was working with
arrays and i guess an array that
contains like hundreds of thousands of
samples and you're shifting one off at
the beginning
javascript's not going to do a great job
of doing that thousands and thousands
and thousands of times
and in fact i changed from uh regular
arrays
to type to raise and it completely
flattened the
performance profile there was there's
like 10 milliseconds the most amount of
time it spends in there rather than
hundreds of milliseconds
and the way that i think about this is a
regular array
is kind of um just a point in memory
which
the operating system doesn't really know
how much it's going to store in memory
and it's kind of any type can go in
there you can put
you know objects and strings and it's
not super optimized when it's in memory
but a typed array
well it can only be one length for
starters so the operating systems kind
of allocates that amount of memory
and the actual elements inside of the
typed array they can only be uh
either a a u and 8 or a
floating point but it has a specific
length so you can very quickly jump
through that typed array
so type to raise was superb for this and
it's runtime performance rather than
kind of like
typescript like protection of uh
of your type i don't know i don't use
typescript but not
as bad okay so
my code is now able to use a script
processor to consume
audio that i can then kind of uh
paint blue and red bars for when i get
data
so i'll get back on my volume okay
nice and loud is that how i want it so
just heads up audio people
you ready
okay i turned out a bit more
so those are the bits that i'm
reconstructing from the sound
and i'm painting it back into the buffer
that middle bit is just for show but the
the bars around the edge the blues are
the um the ones
and uh the yellows are the zeros so
yeah okay
[Applause]
[Music]
right so i have i have slow and i have
loud but i don't have ugly yet
now i don't have any time for webp
or you know pngs or gifs or gifs or
you know those those fancy image formats
what we need
are really old unsupported
spectrum 1980 image formats and so this
is the image format i'm going to render
none of this new stuff um so this is a
this is how
the image is rendered in a spectrum
and it's actually a really cute image
format or i think it is
um it's always exactly 6912 bytes
and it's broken up into these these
sections it's not exactly
quarters but the first three quarters
are pixel data
and it's literally uh if the if the
binary is zero
it is uh white and if it's one it's
black so
on like it's on and off basically the
zeros and ones mean put the pixel on the
screen
so the first third first quarter is
dedicated to the first third of the
screen
second quarter second third and so on
and then the last section at the end is
dedicated to
the attribute data which makes up the
color uh that you see at the bottom
and it's just a um a byte a single byte
gives us the ink the paper the
brightness
and that means basically from instead of
white we can have gray if the brightness
is off and
obviously blink because that's important
okay um
and the great part of this code i think
is um i can
i get to use bitwise operations and i
can say
for any point in my six thousand twelve
hundred and
six thousand nine hundred twelve bytes i
have this this index of like
four thousand where does that live in
the first in in each
quarter and i can do a bit wise shift 11
which um is not only like really
performant because kind of like low
level javascript but it makes me look
like elite
hacker yeah and this is more code that
renders bits and look it's got
uh bit shifting modulus multiplication
some maths yeah
even a weight sleep at the end just to
make it go a little bit slower
and with that i can now render all of
these super
old deprecated formats so these are real
dot screen files from the world of
spectrum
um we got jetpack manic miners one of
the early games
um i've got what we've got chase hq
i mean there's others robocop looks
pretty cool
so now i can support really old
awful image formats yeah
like i said webp done
[Applause]
[Music]
but the internet is littered with
pictures of cats so we need to fix that
as well
i'm going to fix all of the old existing
like old
new images i'm going to altify them okay
and there's this really like
i want to say beautiful kind of aspects
of these these spectrum images because
of the way that the
the pixels are rendered there's this
thing called attribute clash where um
uh the screen is divided into eight by
eight blocks and you can only have two
colors in
each eight by eight block on the
spectrum so you'll get these kind of
like
uh uh detail color that would that can't
it doesn't bleed into like other eight
by eight blocks you can only have two
two colors there okay so
fine fair enough take my picture my cat
i can use a canvas api to like
mangle the bits so i'm going to take an
image and put that into a canvas
so relatively speaking that's
straightforward
i'm going to resize it down to 256x192
because that's how big images should be
um i'm gonna use the atkinson atkinson
yeah accent dither algorithm to
get the colors to kind of shift across
to the 15 colors the spectrum has
that's easy ish depending on whether or
not you like i
know how to copy and paste correctly um
which is
how i code um and then determine
which like getting rid of the other
colors and
uh work out which bits of the ink and
which is the paper and then ditch the
other colors to make it
to make it work which was a little more
complicated i think i just kept throwing
code
in at it until i got something
um so this is a just uh my twitter
avatar can load
into the page if i can find my cursor
screen's really big which means my
cursor might be
hiding
[Music]
come on there we go okay
so my eyeball um so this is just the
regular image
then i do the uh the dither algorithm
okay and i
literally no idea how it works i just
quite literally copy and pasted it and
change the colors
um so end up with this okay now that
eight by eight block
it's got four colors in it and i i can't
do four colors on a spectrum
because it'll look too good um i know
right kind of
too nice um so what i do is i find the
two most popular colors in this case
it's um
black and and gray um and i basically
absorb
oh no i think black and red i don't know
it's gonna be a fight and absorb the
other colors
into those pixels and i end up with this
uh
nightmare mask um but this is the
attribute mask and in this eight by
eight block i now only have
uh pixels that are on and off so i can
then kind of put the popular ones back
in and
i end up with a um compatible
image and i've odified an image um and i
can see this
with the jsconf yeah so you can see with
jsconf
um the attribute uh um clash just here
where you can see i've got kind of like
a darker magenta and a slightly lighter
magenta because of the white
like the the bright bit makes it white
anyway
uh so i'm now
able to make images old okay
you can clap for that if you want to you
don't have to just saying
[Music]
okay so all right we're now able to make
the whole of the internet um awful um
i can now wire this up so i can take
my oldify technique take my mobile phone
i can take an audio cable in theory
plug it into my my laptop
go through the audio process listen load
the bars
and render an old picture of all you
on my computer that's
the plan now the first time i did this i
was like okay i've got the code working
um and um i'll just plug it into the
computer it should work right
um all right let me turn my volume up
turn your volume down over in the corner
yeah there's gonna be some sounds um or
i'll turn mine down a bit i'll turn my
down a bit
um so the first time i ran it this
happened
yep
[Music]
it does like a weird submarine thing
and actually unsurprisingly computers
are really smart
the microphones on your phone and in
your computers are designed to get rid
of background noise
which is what i'm generating so
it hears the noise and it goes no no no
no
no we're not having that so after a lot
of digging around eventually i found
[Music]
the um echo cancellation so if i
listen to that
so you can see i've got a perfect
samples now
so with the echo cancellation turned off
i've turned off all the cool features in
my
my uh my laptop i was able to get the
the awful sound working
properly um okay so
i'm just gonna do a little refresh okay
so this is my
um it's just a canvas spectrum that i
made
it's really nothing more than just some
text and something listen to key so
first thing i need to do is take a photo
of you uh yeah i'll take a photo first
um right
okay uh let's just hang that out there
that'll be fine
okay so um right smile
smile okay yep okay ready on three
right one two three hey
[Music]
yeah i think it's okay your eyes open
that's cool right so
i have the photo on here i'm gonna um
just plug it into the audio jack i have
to get the machine ready
so i'm going to do load and then from
the tape you have to do
empty quotes because i don't know 1980s
and what how's the volume doing oh let's
do that like that
i'm going to hit enter and then i'm
going to hit play now
yeah i've also
find that sometimes it doesn't work
so i've been able to replicate bugs
occasionally
and this is just like i have to hope it
works
kind of looks like what well it doesn't
actually look anything like what the
phone looks like so we're going to just
wait for this
and you realize debugging this i have to
listen to this over and over again
you can't just fast forward it in fact
actually i've
the bit that i've built is the only bit
that in all the emulators like all the
emulated machines don't want to build
i've built the bit that no one wants
um in real games they've just skipped
this bit
for reasons i don't know why wouldn't
you want you ready
this is it
pretty cool
[Applause]
[Music]
i can barely recognize any of you to be
fair but it's it worked right
and i know what you're thinking i did
this on on a computer right
what about an original 1982
zx spectrum yeah i got it working in
there as well this is a video from home
i didn't i didn't dare bring this in
in the corner is a a zx spectrum from
1980
what it was made in 1982 it's obviously
filmed today
um i got the audio jack of my laptop
plugged into it i typed load and
what it's rendering on the screen is
actually rendered inside the spectrum
itself so i'm able to talk
really old language
for no good whatsoever but it it worked
on a real spectrum too so if anyone
needs to put some images on a really old
spectrum come see me
[Music]
okay so i'm slightly over time but the
question of why
um and uh quite honestly this comes up
for myself quite often
every few months i have this crisis of
of faith and i'm quite prepared to just
chuck it all away because really there
is no point
to any of this in some respects but
um some of the sometimes i work on these
side projects for
for love like js bin i i love the
project but at times
i hate the project and that's not a
great relationship either
that's not the why um other times i've
worked on side projects and it brings in
like client work and paid work because i
work for myself that's not always that's
not normally the why
why i do these kind of things the why is
because
i enjoy uh kind of
using code to be creative for myself
and i enjoy puzzle solving and i enjoy
learning new
problems new failings if that makes
sense so
it's mostly for fun thanks